تداول الرواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو لرئيس الاتحاد الكاميروني لكره
القدم ولاعب منتخب الكاميرون السابق
صامويل ايتو وهو يقوم بالاعتداء على
اليوتيوب الجزائري والصانع المحتوى سعيد
ماموني
حيث نشرت صحيفه اسبانيه مقطع فيديو اظهر
اعتدايته بالضرب على اليوتيوب الجزائري
اثناء قيامه بالتقاط صور التذكاريه مع بعض
الجمهور
ولقد تفاجئ الجميع وبعد لحظات بقيام اترو
بركل سعيد بقوه واوقعوا على الارض كما حطم
كاميرته الخاصه
لاحقا ظهر ماموني في مقطع فيديو عبر قناته
على يوتيوب اوضح فيه انه سالته عن ما اذا
كان قد تقدم برشوه لبكار القسامه
كيف
رجعتني
في مركز الشرطه التحقيق
لنهايئات كاس العالم لهذا العام المباراه
الذي فازت فيها الكاميرون في الدقيقه
الرابعه مع الوقت بدل الضائع للوقت
الاضافي واستعرض مامون الكدمات الموجوده
في جسده نتيجه الضرب كما اظهر كاميرته
المحطمه كاميرا
ونشر سعيد ماموني مقطع فيديو عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي كشف فيه تفاصيل
الاعتداء عليه معلنا تقديمه بلاغا في احد
مراكز الشرطه ضد صامويل ايتو مؤكدا ان قطر
دوله قانون وستمنحه حقه
ا لانه نحن من اهل الجزائر